has anybody online figured out your
recipe yet
no no I think Dave's the only I get I
get chefs telling me like man that thing
is impossible to like recreate no
because like you'll see like people be
like this is how you make Dave's sauce
or yeah have you seen those tick tocks
or any of that stuff on YouTube
yeah yeah but they'd ever get it right
no I don't think so I mean it took you
five months to come up with a yeah but
yeah and I think the chances of getting
that uh spice mix recipe right because
there's so many like different grams in
there so there's like 50 grams of
cayenne so even if you mess up one to
two grams it's not gonna we had a
challenge at my house uh in December
where we got the the really hot one the
most hot the reaper oh yeah the reaper
so my my son bought like five of them
and everybody had to take a bite and he
he's the only one who finished one that
[ __ ] is
ridiculous right comfortably it's bad
it's bad yeah and [ __ ] be
eating that [ __ ] like that man it's it's
crazy they go through it bro it messed
my stomach up for a while yeah I can't
go above medium now no I love that
Medium is where I'm at it's my size give
me that medium and I love the sauce has
anyone gotten the sauce right
not the like no we bro the sauce is so
good the sauce is hard to make man I'm
not gonna lie yeah it's really complex
yeah but you know what's what's
hilarious is we used to have these Army
and ladies that worked for us and they
they one of them is the sauce recipe she
knew yeah and when they left the job I
thought every chicken spot was recorded
yeah they were like Contracting her oh
she was selling the secret sauce yeah oh
five year deal come play with us and
it's funny because
it is kind of like an Armenian Rand
industry in L.A most hot chicken places
are Armenian owned uh I wonder why I
wonder am I tripping you're not man I
don't think Alan raises but I think most
of the spots yeah it is Armenian owned
our means are like they're quick to
catch on yeah they're quick to jump on
things I mean we're Armenian we saw it
quick we jumped on it right yeah
um but every all of my favorite
restaurants are by the way are Armenian
owns you guys got it figured out in the
[ __ ] Valley I feel we're pretty good
with food man we have a good palette but
I think another thing is like
when we got into it there was almost
like this genuine intention of like
let's create this really really good
food that we can serve to people and be
proud of it and you know join it on this
trend but not for the sake of the trend
just to like because we love this food
too and we want to make our best version
of it of course and Dave being a chef he
was very passionate about it right
whereas uh and not everybody but a lot
of other people oh God it's like a cash
grab it's like this exactly yeah
it's like oh hot chickens in it's
selling right now oh they got a line
what are they making hot chicken cool
throw it on the menu is there anybody
else's hot chicken that you've tried
that you like I love Holland race yeah
I love them dude that's what I've heard
I've heard I want to try Helen Ray's
because I've heard uh my boy estad who's
Armenian you guys might know him yeah we
do he's a homie yeah great school as
hell uh s dots like yo you got to go to
Holland race Holland's fire yeah and I
assumed it was Armenian owned because s
dot always puts me on those spots yeah
and he's like it's not Armenian you know
it's good if I'm telling you it's like
if it's not Army you know you're like
you know it's good now look they're
they're another one of those Brands
where like the guys just genuinely loves
food and he loves chicken yeah he's a
chef he does it for the food right and
you know that because he hasn't expanded
like crazy he looks loves the food I
think that's dope you guys can
acknowledge that too you know yeah man
there's a lot dude we love chicken man
you gotta love all kinds of chicken and
you know especially when we're working
on the recipe all we did is eat
different chickens there used to be a
tent right here on Vineland and Magnolia
in the Walgreens parking lot and their
[ __ ] was solid I don't know what
happened to them oh that was my cousin
no I'm just kidding it might have been I
don't even know it could have been um